um
tracy brabin the chancellor says he's
sending you a really big wad
um you must be pretty cheerful this
morning
well good morning trevor yes it is good
news and certainly i'm pleased that
governments are
chiming with us about our ambitions for
our region but as you heard from rachel
earlier in your program this is only one
part of the jigsaw we can't talk about
leveling up if we don't talk about
another
rail line the northern powerhouse rail
that'll have that stop at st james's in
bradford bradford is one of the youngest
cities in the whole country we want to
connect those young people to jobs and
opportunities but of course hs2 we've
had briefings and counter briefings and
rumors we absolutely need to know that
that is going to happen we need that new
station in leeds leeds already is at
capacity we have the land allocated we
have the ambition for it we are ready to
live to
deliver as labour mayors and um i'm glad
government see the uh the opportunity
and we're happy to work with them
well i don't know if you heard my
interview with the chancellor earlier uh
tracy braven but um when i asked him
about the stop in bradford and the
extension to lead
he was um at best i would say enigmatic
he didn't
he didn't embrace the opportunity to say
ah yes and of course look out for
announcements on that um
not really that good news
well we've been waiting for the
integrated rail plan as you heard from
the from the chancellor for quite some
time i've been pressing for more
information but i was at the global
investment summit only last week and
heard the prime minister talk
specifically about northern powerhouse
rail but what's important for us is that
stop in bradford we can't have a
watered-down version of our transport
network here in west yorkshire we have
had 174 pounds per head spent on
transport in london it's over 500 pounds
we have less per head than any other
community across the country we've been
underfunded for decades now is the
opportunity for government to be bold to
be ambitious to come with us with our
vision for west yorkshire to have that
london style uh transport system that
will really make us that powerhouse we
can be
so you you rather share rachel reeves
skepticism that says
uh this is an announcement
but we're not seeing delivery yet
well we're still waiting for the detail
i think there is tension potentially
between number 10 and number 11 between
maybe what the prime minister wants to
see and what rishi sunak thinks that he
can afford but actually it's going to
cost us all not to deliver a gold-plated
five-star transport system for west
yorkshire
uh can i ask about another aspect of the
spending um program um the skills
proposal um there's a lot of money going
to be spent on skills and i guess a lot
of some of it will go to
your towns your fe colleges and so on
but do you worry that you will be
training people in bradford and
wakefield just so that they can hop on a
new rail line if you get it to work in
manchester
no that's not necessarily the whole
picture because when it comes to skills
obviously we want young people to choose
their first
choice of college and not have to choose
their third because they can't get to
their first because there's poor
transport but what's been really
interesting regarding skills obviously
it's going to be in the detail but the
government are talking about t levels in
particular but um having spent time with
college principals only a couple of
weeks ago i was hearing how tricky that
is uh with t levels to get the right
businesses to get businesses to come on
board with t levels i really do believe
apprenticeships are the way to genuinely
level up but it is a part of a holistic
picture trevor that you can't level up
just with skills alone of course they're
important you have to have that
transport system to get people to those
opportunities to learning
when we think about apprenticeships um
actually
the picture hasn't been that fantastic
has it i mean we know that a lot of
businesses uh it is estimated that
something like 5000 big businesses
didn't take up their full entitlement
under the apprenticeship levy and that
400 million
pounds worth of apprenticeship levy
money simply expired because uh you
can't if you don't use it you lose it um
is there anything that you think we need
to do with the apprenticeship
program to make it more user-friendly so
more people can get onto it because
otherwise
uh it's a lot of noise without much
substance isn't it
i absolutely agree and having uh had a
meeting with the ceo of ocado a couple
of years ago when i was the member of
parliament for badly and spent they paid
the levied they can't recruit this is
not right and that's why i'm really
pleased across where shark shall we
support businesses to share that
apprenticeship levy to make sure that
those smaller smes can get the talented
apprentices that that they need in order
to expand but i would also say having uh
visited a really brilliant local company
that's in aerospace produ max
only a couple of weeks ago talking about
apprentices it's really important that
we make sure that those from black asian
and minority ethnic backgrounds also get
that opportunity to get an
apprenticeship with a really fantastic
company that's my approach as the mayor
that's we have some powers over skills
and i was able to launch a six million
pound program to have modular skills
offer for those uh people who've been
made redundant after furlough or young
people have not been able to just get
started after covid so that they can do
shorter programs because there are some
challenges to full-time programs when
people have to pay their bills and earn
a living so it's really an exciting time
for west yorkshire finally we have
devolution i'm six months into the job
but it's a it's a point that now we're
uh able to deliver obviously we want to
work with government to help them
deliver on their leveling up ambitions
and we're here and we're ready to do it
um can i turn to the other big story of
the day as it is pretty much every week
and that is covid um the health
secretary this week came on a bit like
um school headmaster and uh said that if
we didn't do better on mask wearing and
so on then we'd all be back in detention
what's the mood in west yorkshire
well it is a really troubling time
let's not forget that west yorkshire has
been in restrictions for most of the 18
months our businesses and our high
streets have really suffered so many
people have lost so much over these last
uh awful 18 months it's uh it's
troubling looking at the next few months
i was able with my limited powers to be
able to mandate for mask wearing in bus
stations obviously sadiq khan has
different powers he could say across all
of transport musk wearing to be a
priority and to be mandated we will be
working with councils to find the best
way towards christmas but of course
let's not forget it was councils that
really supported us during the last few
months whether that was testing tracking
and tracing
finding uh laptops for kids that didn't
have tech that are rolling out the
vaccination program this is labour
councils particularly in west yorkshire
that have delivered for their community
and i know we'll continue to do so and
to try and keep people safe
tracy brabin um
politics has been consumed in the last
week
if i may
raise this with the aftermath of the
death of david amos and you yourself
obviously um
have been close to this issue
do you what's your take uh if i may ask
for you know 30 seconds
does politics need to be kinder and
gentler
well of course and you'll know um how i
came into parliament that terrible
tragedy when we lost joe cox i said to
my family who were worried when i took
up the role it was a once in a lifetime
lightning strike it would never happen
again and sadly here we are five years
later of course politics has to be
kinder we need to also provide mental
health support in our communities people
have suffered a lot we need to make sure
that there is provision to to help those
people who are feeling angry and
frustrated obviously um so david amis is
a a fine uh human and and certainly he
was very kind to me when i was a member
of parliament and an and an inveterate
letter writer i had a number of letters
from him but it's an awful time and
obviously we need to do more and i'm
really pleased that my colleagues in
westminster are taking up the mantle to
make sure that we can certainly in the
online space with the online
bills white paper that we can online
harm's white paper that we can make sure
that there is legislation to protect
people